il a tout vécu à cannes la joie la
frustration parfois le doute certains
films sont très bien reçu d'autres le
sont un peu moins mais cannes et surtout
pour vous aviez dolan synonyme de
consécration
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dix ans après avoir tué sa mère le
cinéaste est revenu sur le terrain de
ses premières amours
entouré de ses meilleurs amis
dolan transformer libéré semble-t-il de
la pression de plaire à tout prix
on l'a déjà connu torturé il est
aujourd'hui serein et détendu alors
autour des bus vous comprenez histoire
commence avec un but bien entendu nous
allons bien j'aime mathias et maxime est
un film écrit et tourné à plusieurs
mains un film sur l'amitié fait par des
amis j'ai expérimenté le sentiment de
l'amitié en groupe
et puis j'avais envie à travers ce film
entre autres choses de leur rendre
hommage de rendre hommage à la force de
ses de ses amitiés là on peut comme ans
de la vie de xavier dolan
mathias et maxime est un film charnière
la fin d'un cycle et le début de quelque
chose d'autre
oui c'est un film de transition c'est un
film qui met d'abord cgj j'ai 30 ans
puis j'arrive à la fin de deux marins
peine si je peux passer ma vie non plus
à filmer des gens qui s'engagent dans
une cuisine fait les chemins quelques
mètres des chiffres bons films et un 30
ans xavier dolan a déjà huit longs
métrages à son actif l'occasion de
regard en arrière
à chaque film on fait des nouvelles
erreurs on apprend on n'essaie pas les
répéter
on en fait d'autres des nouvelles quoi
qu'il arrive le cinéaste entend marquer
une pause après ce film se consacrer
davantage à son métier d'acteur jouer
réalisé - peut-être - rapidement
un rythme plus sain pour la première
fois depuis ses débuts à cannes xavier
dolan est arrivé ici sans attente
mais si les critiques cinéma ont parfois
été dur avec lui les jurys de kano ont
toujours jusqu'à présent reconnu son
génie le palmarès de soixante douzième
festival du cinéma de cannes va être
connus samedi
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
gamme